DR. OZ IN MANHATTAN, HERE HE IS.
>> Sean: MAJESTIC, THE ONLY
WORDS I CAN SAY.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE, INCREDIBLE.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT, WE BEGIN WITH FACTS
WITHOUT FEAR BROADCASTING LIVE
ON THE GROUND IN NEW YORK CITY
WHERE THE COMFORT, A 1,000 BED
U.S. NAVAL HOSPITAL SHIP IS NOW
DOCKED.
THIS IS A FLOATING CITY.
IS MASSIVE.
NORMALLY STATIONED IN NORFOLK,
VIRGINIA, AND MANNED BY A HIGHLY
TRAINED, HIGHLY SKILLED MEMBERS
OF THE U.S. NAVY, THE COMFORT
WILL BEGIN RECEIVING PATIENTS AS
EARLY AS TOMORROW MORNING.
THE SHIP WILL SERVE AS A SUPPORT
SYSTEM HOUSING NONCORONAVIRUS
CASES IN ORDER TO FREE UP BEDS
OF COVID-19 PATIENTS FOR
NEW YORK HOSPITALS.
.
IS EQUIPPED WITH 12 OPERATING
ROOMS, 12.
20 SURGICAL RECOVERY ROOMS, 80
INTENSIVE CARE BEDS, AND 900
ADDITIONAL BEDS FOR OTHER CASES.
COMING UP, THE CAPTAIN OF THE
COMFORT WILL TAKE US INSIDE THIS
INCREDIBLE SHIP, AN AMAZING
FLOATING HOSPITAL.
OF COURSE, THE ENORMOUS SURGE OF
PATIENTS AT NEW YORK HOSPITALS
IS JUST ONE PART OF WHAT IS A
MASSIVE SUPPORT EFFORTS NOW
UNDERWAY ALL THROUGHOUT NEW YORK
AND THE COUNTRY.
AT NEW YORK, THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS HAVE NOW JUST
COMPLETED THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
TEMPORARY HOSPITAL FOR NEARLY
3,000 BEDS AND THEY DID IT IN
RECORD TIME.
MULTIPLY OTHER TEMPORARY
HOSPITAL SURROUNDING NEW YORK
ARE NOW ALSO BEING ERECTED.
FIVE OF THEM.
NOW FRIDAY, THE PRESIDENT
APPROVED MORE RIGHT INSIDE
NEW YORK CITY.
ALL TOLD, THE U.S. ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS IS STEPPING OVER 100
SITES NATIONWIDE TO BE USED AS A
POTENTIAL EMERGENCY HOSPITALS.
ALL IN RECORD TIME.
WE ARE TRULY BLESSED TO LIVE IN
A COUNTRY WITH SO MANY AMAZING
PEOPLE.
THIS IS ALL PART OF WHAT IS THE
LARGEST, THE SINGLE MOST
AGGRESSIVE FULL-FLEDGED RESPONSE
TO BEAT BACK THE SILENT ENEMY.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN SUCH
MOBILIZATION OF FORCES AGAINST
ANY PANDEMIC EVER IN HISTORY.
AND NOW THE GREAT AMERICAN
PRIVATE SECTOR ARE MOBILIZED,
FORD AND GM ARE NOW PLANNING THE
PRODUCTION OF 50,000
VENTILATORS.
THAT’S COMING UP SOON.
GENERAL MOTORS WILL HAVE 10,000
OF THOSE WE EXPECT BY MID-APRIL.
ON THE CALIFORNIA-BASED ARE NOW
STARTING TO MASS-PRODUCE
VENTILATORS AS WELL SHOULD THEY
BE NEEDED.
MY PILLOW, HAYNES, JOCKEY,
PROCTER & GAMBLE, RAYTHEON, ALL
HANDS ON DECK RAMPING UP THE
MASS PRODUCTION OF MASKS AND
GLOVES AND OTHER VITAL MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
AND BY THE WAY BREAKING TODAY
AFTER GETTING EMERGENCY APPROVAL
FROM THE FDA, ABBOTT LABS --
THIS IS HUGE -- THEY HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY CREATED A TEST FOR
COVID-19 THAT CAN GET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE RESULTS IN
AROUND 5 MINUTES AND EVERY STATE
WILL NOW RECEIVE AT LEAST 15 OF
ABBOTT’S TESTING MACHINES WHICH
CAN PERFORM UP TO 50,000 TESTS
PER DAY.
WE HAVE MORE GOOD NEWS FROM THE
TREATMENT POINT AND THE FRONT
THEY ARE.
WE’VE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT
THIS ANTIMALARIA DRUG.
USED FOR LUPUS AS WELL.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE HAS NOW BEEN
AUTHORIZED FOR EMERGENCY USE
NATIONWIDE AFTER PROMISING
RESULTS FROM SEVERAL PRELIMINARY
STUDIES.
NOW, THE PHARMACEUTICAL GIANT
WHICH IS DESCRIBED AS ONE OF
THOSE EVIL PHARMACEUTICAL
CORPORATIONS BY MANY PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA ARE
STEPPING UP TOO.
THEY’RE DONATING 130 MILLION
DOSES OF THIS DRUG FOR TREATMENT
TREATMENT.
AND MEANWHILE, ISRAELI
PHARMACEUTICAL GIANT ANNOUNCED
SUPPLY WITH 6 MILLION DOSES
ALREADY ANOTHER 4 MILLION
REPORTEDLY ON THE WAY.
DR. OZ WILL WEIGH IN AND GET
THIS, THE PHASE ONE TESTING OF A
VACCINE IS ALREADY UNDERWAY.
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT USED TO
TAKE YEARS.
THEY WERE ABLE TO BREAK DOWN A
SEQUENCE OF THIS VIRUS IN ABOUT
SIX WEEKS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR, MAKE NO
MISTAKE, EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
BUCKLE UP.
WE ARE ABOUT TO EXPERIENCE WHAT
WILL BE A VERY HARD AND VERY
DIFFICULT AND VERY EMOTIONALLY
DRAINING THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
THE NUMBERS OF INFECTIONS,
NUMBERS OF DEATHS WILL CONTINUE
TO RISE, BUT IF THE PATTERNS WE
HAVE SEEN ELSEWHERE AROUND THE
WORLD HOLD INCLUDING CHINA,
SOUTH KOREA NOW BEGINNING TO SEE
AND IN ITALY AND ELSEWHERE AFTER
THAT INCREASE, WILL SEE A
LEVELING OFF AND THEN WE HOPE
FOR THE PRECIPITOUS DECLINE.
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IS FACING
A MASSIVE HEALTH CHALLENGE.
WE AMERICANS ARE THE
UNITED STATES, HOME OVER THE
BRAVE, LAND OF THE FREE.
THAT’S US.
WE ARE RISING TO THE OCCASION.
NOW, WILL EVERYTHING BE PERFECT?
NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT, BUT THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE USUAL SUSPECTS
IN THE MEDIA MOB AND OF COURSE
DO NOTHING PSYCHOTIC HATE TRUMP
DEMOCRATS, THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY IS ALL HANDS ON DECK.
AND THANKS TO AMERICAN
INGENUITY, HARD WORK,
DETERMINATION, WE WILL GET
THROUGH THIS.
WE WILL RECOVER.
WE WILL BE BETTER.
WE WILL BE STRONGER.
WE ARE REWRITING THE BOOKS ONTO
PARADIGMS RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
A TRANSFORMATIONAL TIME AND I
GUARANTEE YOU, YOU WON’T BE
CALLING A TRAVEL BAN XENOPHOBIC
AND FEARMONGERING AND SO ONE.